you turned back to God are you the
anomaly are you cutting against the
current of the whole culture or is there
something in the air by which people are
moving away from New Age spirituality or
call it what it is witchcraft back to
God which way is which way is the
culture going what I'm sensing around is
that the people are hungry for Spiritual
things yeah even those that say that you
know um we don't believe in anything I'm
just really like like scientists and
statistics and numbers and things like
this but there is a hung for Spiritual
things and I see that there is Revival
in our s people are coming out of the
occultism coming out of the Witchcraft
coming out of Satanism coming out of all
of those things because they have
realized that now their eyes have been
open to this but I also say that I see
those that they don't know where to go
they're gravitating towards that this is
why I believe as as the church we need
to be a strong and talking more about
spiritual things